jack what's up brother so recently uh
we've had
an act of infidelity within our marriage
and and i was the one that fought
um man you talked a circle around that
one dude
yeah did i yeah let's do this
let's back it up and say hey deloney i
screwed up i need your help
say it like that okay okay hey dr dolone
i screwed up and i need your help
you got it brother so what's up man what
happened
so um i guess this wasn't a
physical act of infidelity but it was uh
something online
an app where i i tried to reach out to
someone
from my past okay um
obviously my wife saw that and um
this was several months ago we've we
both kind of committed to
to making things work and making things
better i've been going to see a
therapist
okay several times a month um but
there's still
how's that going good days and it's it's
good it's
i think i am learning a lot of tools
from that um
and and i've been able to apply a lot of
them and it has helped
um but there's still bad days too what's
that what's a bad day mean what's that
mean
a bad day more or less you know i could
just tell that
that my wife is upset and you know i
know the cause of that
and it's it's something that it's
crushed her confidence
um you know she's wondering is this
going to happen again things like that
so i guess i'm trying to do what i can
to
to restore that trust and i know it's
not
on my timeline but it's just uh
i just want some advice on that and um
we're also expecting a child so ah
congratulations man
and why not make it more complicated
right yeah yeah
perfect timing was she um was she
pregnant when you reached out to
somebody from your past
no okay oh so you found out about this
later
yes cool okay number one
i hate that yellow going through this
and i appreciate you being honest
from this point forward if you've got
people that you trust that you're having
this conversation with
talking in loops like you feel like
we've had this act of
infidelity just cut to it brother just
be straight
i screwed up and i am working to build
something new with
the woman that i love and that i want to
be with forever and who by the way is
not going to be the mother of my kid
cool i want you to be that direct that's
a sink that's cut to it
and get to it is that cool yep all right
so
thank you for your trust man so when you
say that she
has bad days how do you know she's
having a bad day
um i i can just read her mood uh
usually she's and i'll tell you that's
dangerous when you get into her head
right and you try to figure out what's
going on and while it's probably about
this
does she tell you hey i am having a
vulnerable day
or i just woke up thinking about that
other girl and i
just started spinning out does she tell
you those things or are you both
imagining what's going on in the other
person's head uh
probably a little both usually i ask
though and
you know if i'd ask she's she's pretty
direct and upfront about what's
got her down okay and what weighs inside
of the house
like concrete steps have you taken to
help rebuild trust in your home have you
given her access to your phone have you
does she have all your email accounts
like what are the things that you're
doing
so that she can begin rebuilding trust
in a very practical way
oh yeah yeah she she has access to to
all of that and beyond
um as far as
you know actual ways i'm trying to
go about this i mean just kind of
yeah i guess with my therapist we've
talked a lot about love languages and
ways that
and and then the the gottman's four
horsemen i'm sure you've heard of
um just trying to be proactive and
uh tend to her the ways that she
receives
affection and things that matter to her
kind of tend to that
um so one of the things i i love
you know i like the idea of the love
languages i like i mean gottman is
is the pinnacle right there they do more
relationship research i think anybody on
earth
one of the challenges i see especially
in young relationships
is trying to get your
like unplug your wife from who she is
and plug her into one of these
categories
and so i want you to know these are
frames but they're not
her right yeah yeah and learning to
really sit down
what what what this is kind of a loaded
question
what made you reach out to somebody else
what was missing
in your home what was missing inside of
you
i think just well i've listened to you
for a while and i think just um
just getting another perspective on
advice you know
no no what made you reach out to
an old girlfriend oh um
yeah i think that's a loaded question i
i think i've i've been trying to dive in
and that's one of the things that um
i've really tried to dive in within the
therapy itself
is to find a why and i don't know if it
is one answer
you know i think it's a lot of things um
it's a lot of the wrong things i mean
there's nothing that justifies that so
i think you're really wise to
understand the complexity that i'm
usually troubled by folks who just
are able to say well it's because of
this oh man it's usually a lot messier
messier thing than that
so is your wife going to see somebody
she's not um i mean she's not entirely
opposed to it but i think it was more of
like
this was my mistake this is my have you
all seen anybody together
no okay i think that's primo numero uno
is you all got to see somebody together
here's why
when something like this happens
occasionally but not always
occasionally it's one idiot there's just
one
idiot in the relationship that did
something stupid and now we just got to
get that
person he or she you know got to hit
them with a stick
and get them to change their ways
usually
there is some sort of dance there's some
sort of
i'm missing this need here so i'm trying
to fill this gap in and then i return to
my default settings and this brings up
this stuff and it just turns into this
weird just tr
like just mess right and
moving forward yes learning the love
languages learning about the four
horsemen learning about ways you can
theoretically support her learning about
ways you can theoretically hurt her
that's important
but what's really important is y'all
learn how you all talk to each other
you all learn what safety you all learn
what desire
you all learn what the rules and
boundaries are and you decide your
relationship
which means you all have to work on
building something new together
because what's happening is right now is
you're off so
you've heard me use say this before like
you blew up the building
right how long have you been married a
little over here
okay i don't even say you blew it up all
right i'm not even gonna put that on you
you um you a grenade went off in one of
the
in one of the in one of the foundation
pillars right and that sucker started
rocking
and what you did what you all have done
is you went off to get some more
classes on architecture on engineering
and your job is to come back and rebuild
that pillar that's just not how the way
that's going to work
okay you are going to have to both go
and say okay this building that we had
we're a year in it's a really
it's a one-story building it's little
we're gonna have to scrap it and build
something new and that's cool because
we're gonna build something stronger
more beautiful that's going to be able
to hold a child it's going to be able to
hold all this stuff
but we got to do it together right and i
want you guys to do this thing together
right do y'all have any couples that are
5 years 10 years
15 years ahead of you all that you meet
with y'all hang out with
oh yeah okay do they know about what
happened
no no we've kind of kept it private all
right
secrecy kills or as brene brown says
shame eats secrecy that's what feeds it
and when you shine a light on something
it loses its power
and my recommendation is you invite a
couple over that you trust that's 5
10 15 years ahead of y'all down the road
from you guys
and y'all be totally open and when your
wife opens
up and talks about how much this hurt
and how much it caught her off guard how
much she was surprised all those things
you don't get to respond
other than yeah i hurt her that's it no
excuses no
this isn't yeah i really messed up and
then when you talk about it no
big just direct straightforward here's
what happened this is this is
the way this is and that way y'all can
cut to
cut through some of the nonsense but you
get that thing out of there and your
wife right now feels like she is
shouldering all of this
and she's having to reconcile i'm still
super pissed off at this dude and i'm
pregnant
but he's going to counseling like i said
he had to and he's
love languaging me right he's making my
coffee and i'm still
mad and that what's going to happen is
she's going to start to blame herself
open this up go see somebody together
she all can rebuild something new get
some new skills y'all are still super
young into this thing
don't give up on it especially you got a
kid on the way
go into it open-hearted open-minded
we're going to learn new skills and
i want you to start shining some light
in this thing it's going to be a part of
your story forever it is what it is what
it is
get some people who've got some wisdom
and some experience on top of you
i want to commend you for coming forward
commend you for
trying to do the work now you got to
bring her along with you this is not
something you can do on your own you got
to bring her along there with you
okay you're going to find out things
about each other you didn't know
that you like more that scare you you're
going to work on a language
of the relationship of jack and i'm
going to call her diane
jack and diane you're going to learn
that language together as you move
forward